in this course antonio papa will teach
you how to create a microservices
project using fast api react and redis
antonio has a bunch of experience with a
lot of different tech stacks
in this video we will build a simple
micro services app using python fast api
the front end of this app will be in
react and we will have two main micro
services
one is the inventory microservice and
the other one is the payment
microservice the inventory microservice
will store products and the payment
microservice will purchase those
products the data will be stored in
redis so we will use the redis json
database which is a database similar to
mongodb
and we will send events uh from one
microservice to another using redis
streams so that is another functionality
of redis
i choose this architecture because
we will not use any other database or
rabbitmq or kafka we can use redis for
all the needs that we have now let's see
the app that we are going to build also
make sure to check my channel scalable
scripts where here i have a lot of
projects and more microservices
tutorials if you are interested now
let's move to the app
this is the app that we will build so it
is very simple we can create products
here which i will create one right now
so i'll call it product
i'll set up price and the quantity
when i create we will have a product
created with this id here and we have
the option to delete this product so
this is the first microservice and the
other microservice is purchasing that
product
here we need to copy this id
and when i paste this id we can see that
your product price is 24
now you may be confused because the
price here is 20 and here is 24.
the reason that i increase the price
here is uh think of it as another
app that
buys the products from this uh
warehouse you can
think of it
and
on top of that it will add
20 fee so
it is 24 because it is 20
more
so
that's it when
the user buys this product
this app
will gain
profits and also the warehouse also
i will buy a quantity of three
i'll buy
and here it says thank you for your
order and
if we refresh we won't see it
immediately because it needs five
seconds to update
and now the quantity is
97 so
the app
will seem very easy but
there is lot of asynchronous stuff going
in the background and also redis
stream events so we will see it now when
we build the backend
now let's create the projects go to
fastapi.tagolo.com
and here
we will see the instructions to install
fast api and uv corn
after you install these two packages
click tutorial first steps and i'll copy
this code here
now i will open my ide and i have two
projects here so the first one is
inventory where here we will store
products
and also their quantities
and the payment project where we will
purchase those products
so these are the two microservices that
we will work in the this tutorial
we have a main.pi file which currently
it is empty and the
requirements.txt where we have all the
packages that we need like fast api and
redis om we will use redis as a database
we will store
our products there but also we will use
redis as
event sourcing software like rabbitmq
and kafka so
we will use it for multiple cases
now let's go to main.pipe
and i will paste the code that i just
copied and to run this code now
simply run the command
which is showed here uvicorn main up
reload
so
this is a command and it will run this
app on port 8000
now
let's test that end point and to test
that endpoint i will use a tool called
postman so this
tool helps us to
test
api endpoints i will open the tool now
it is free
i will open a new tab and i will send a
get request to http localhost port 8000
and if i send the request we will see
hello world here
so we created our first endpoint and now
we want to create a database where we
want to store products here for that i
will use redis so go to redis.com
and we need to try
the redis cloud for free now i'm logged
in to redis cloud and here we need to
create a new subscription so there is a
free plan available
i'm located in europe
and
i will select this free plan 30
megabytes the subscription name i'll
call it microservices
and that's it we created this plan and
now we need to create a new database
i'll call it this database redis
db
and for the models i will select ready
search and reduce json so already json
is a database just like mongodb energy
search
adds some functionality to search that
database like
it is similar to elasticsearch
and i will activate this database
so the database was created successfully
and as you can see here we have a public
endpoint which we will use it uh right
now and we need also the default user
password
which we will copy as well so
that's it now
in this invertory app
i will connect with redis and
we need to use this package called redis
om
i will copy it
and i will install install it via pip so
pip
install
redis om
and
let's uh import it here so from
redis
om
we need to import
get redis connection and with this we
will
connect to redis i'll do it here so red
is
uh
it is equal to get redisconnection
inside we need to pass the host
which in our case is this public
endpoint i will copy the public endpoint
and i will paste it here
but we don't need the port so i'll cut
the port here
because the port will be another
variable so port here
is equal to this value and then we need
the
password
which
it is this user password value here
which i will copy
and i'll paste it here so this is my
password
don't use my credentials because i will
remove this connection once this
tutorial is over so you have to create
your own credentials
and then the code responses it is equal
to true
so that should be it
we created the connection via redis and
now we want to create a model that will
be converted to a table
in
the redis database so for that i'll
create a class here
product
and from redis om we need to import also
hash model
and this product will extend from hash
model
and let's add all the values that the
product has so the product has a name
which should be a string
then it has a price
which it is an integer
and a quantity
which it is an integer actually i will
change the price i will make it a float
better
and that's it so this product will have
just a name a price and
this quantity is the quantity available
i will keep it short so it could be
quantity available
but i will just keep it quantity so i
will keep it short
and to make this
product connect with our redis database
we need to add another class here meta
and inside we'll say that the database
will be equal to
redis
and that should be it so with this
uh
every time we query and we create
products they will it will be stored in
our redis connection and let's do that
i will remove this end point here
and i'll create a function
products
or all
doesn't matter
uh let's return an empty
list for the moment this will be
a get request
to slash products
and that's it so let's test this
endpoint on postman
if we send a get request to
localhost port 8000 slash products
so we have an error
is your corn running it seems it's not
and we can see an empty array right now
so it is uh this simple
now
we need to return the products
from redis and to do that we have to
return products
that all underscore primary keys
so
this is
the function that will return all the
products
i will save it
and for the moment we don't have any
but this
will return only the primary keys and
this will not return the products
for the moment we cannot see it but we
need to create another endpoint to
create a product to see what this
returns
we will do that but first we need to
create also a middleware here
so
we need to add a middleware called
course
let's import it here
so from
fast api
middleware course we need to import
the course middleware
and we need to add it here
so what is course so course is a problem
that when we run our front end it will
run on port 3000
and the uv cord here is running on port
8000 so it's not running for the moment
i will fix that
but
there are different ports and the
browser will prevent that in order to
prevent that
problem we need to add the middleware
also we need to specify the allowed
origins so allow
origins
here will be http
localhost
for 3000
so this is our frontend we need to allow
the frontend to request our apis
we need the
the methods so i'll copy this
paste it here so this is allow
methods
i'll put the star here so all the
methods and
we need to allow headers
so
that should be it this won't change
anything
until now
so the app will work the same but the
changes will be reflected on the front
end so we won't have
problems
in the front end if we add this
middleware and now
let's create the other end point where
we create products so i'll create a
function here create
and uh
fast api makes it really simple for us
first i will add here the method so
up post method
to slash products
and to create
a product we need to pass in the
parameters here the product itself
as a product
and we need to return product
save
it is this simple so the parameters that
we need to send in the request
are the name of the price and the
quantity
and the rest
will be taken care from fast api
so
let's see if this works i'll copy this
open a new tab i'll send a post request
and in the body
i'll send a json
i'll send a name
product
i'll send the price
20
and a quantity available
i'll say 100 so
if we send this request we can see that
we get a primary key a name the price
and the quantity so the product was
created successfully and if we try this
request again
we can see that we are returning a
primary key but i don't want to return
just a primary key i want to return
all the
objects
and we need to create another function
for me for it so i'll create a function
here format
and in this function we need to pass a
primary key as a string
so we will pass the
all the primary keys to this function
we need to get the product
which is equal to product that get
with this primary key so this will query
that
product from the database and we want to
return
the response of this so
i want to display the primary key i will
display directly the id which is product
dot primary key
we need the name
which is product dot name
we need the price which is
product
that price
and we need the quantity
which is product that quantity
and for this function now
we need to return an array now
that we'll do something here
for primary key in
product
all primary keys
and this something will be
calling this format function that we
just created and i will pass the primary
key there
so that's it
uh with this change
now
so it seems uv corn stopped again
we can see now the response is what i
wanted so we have an array of products
with the id name price and quantity
so that's it we need also one last
method which is deleting this product
actually we need two so i'll add the
first one so def
get
with a primary key as a string
so this will get a single product from
an id
and this will be a get request
get to
products
slash the primary key here
and we will return product
that get
with the primary key
let's see if uvicorn is running it is so
if i copy this id
and i will
put it here
we can see that we are returning not an
array now but
directly the object so
this is working fine and now let's add
the last one which is deleting this
product so
delete here
and we need to pass again the primary
key
as a string
i'll copy this part
i'll paste it here and this is a delete
method
and we will get the product
like this so product
is equal to product get with this
primary key and we will return
product that delete
if we try this
method now
this will be a delete request
so we have a problem
what is the problem now
it seems that uh
we need
a primary key here so maybe i made a
mistake
we should do it like this then
so now it should work so my bet there
and now it is working not sure why it
returns one but it means uh it probably
means that it is successful
now if we get all the products
we don't have any so
we created a simple crowd for the
products and now let's move to the
payment microservice let's go to the
main.pi file and let's add
all these parts
and i'll paste it here so we still need
the course middleware we need to create
a fast api project
and we need to connect to a database
i'll copy this again
and i'll paste it here
a lot of comments
here and i will say this should
be a different
database
so the point of microservices is that
each microservice needs their own
database i will keep the same database
because if we go to
the redis cloud
if we add a new subscription
let me open it here
not sure
it is here
we need to pay
still i have 200 dollars in three
credits but
in this case
it won't make a difference since it will
be another database i will use the same
database
but
keep in mind that this could be
not a radius database but a mongodb or a
mysql database so this is not a problem
in what i'm trying to teach you
and now let's create
the class for this
microservice what we need to create
and it will be an order so this will
extend from the hash model
and what does the order table
has as a column so it has a product id
as a string
so when we create an order we need to
know which
product id we are buying and that
product id has a price
which is a float
and this microservice will
buy that product with that price but it
will also add a
so think of it as
you are
getting items from
a warehouse
but you also need your own revenue so
you
add the fee on top of the price that you
buy on that warehouse
and also price plus fee
it mean it needs a total here
which is also a float
the total price that the user pays
the quantity
is an integer
so this is a quantity that the user buys
and the status
so this is important so the status is
pending
i will add a comment here so pending
completed
and refunded
so we will handle all these cases in
this tutorial pending is when we create
this
record in our database but the payment
processor hasn't completed yet
this status is when the payment
processor approves our request and
refunded is when an error happens which
i will show you later
when
that error happens and how we will
handle it so we need the meta here
and we need to connect with the database
which is redis
so that's it we created also another
model and here
let's add
the
method so we need to create a function
create
this will be a post request
to
orders
and we will pass a request here
so we need to import a request
i will import it directly so i have a
lot of imports there
from
starlet
requests
import request
so this is what we want
and then
what do we want to do right now
first we know that fast api supports
asynchronous requests
and asynchronous functions
and i will get the body
of that request
by awaiting requests
that json
so this is one way of getting all the
data in the request
but
i will show you later
a better way of handling asynchronous
tasks but for the moment
let's get just the body
and here
we will send just
an id
and a quantity
and from that id
we want to get
the products and all the information
regarding that product so
now comes the first problem of
microservices how do we get that
information
that information we will get it
if we request directly the inverter in
microservice so we request this endpoint
here
and we retrieve
that information and to do that we need
to install another package
pip install
requests
so it is installed and we need to import
it here so import
requests
so
let's send now a get request to the
inventory microservice so the request
will be equal to requests
we'll send a get request to
http
localhost port 8000 slash
products slash
percentage s so this is a string so we
need to pass the id
of the product which we get it from the
body
and that will be converted
like this with a percentage body id
so this value will be converted
to this value
and in the end
let's see what this returns i will
return request
dot json
and let's see what this returns so first
we don't have any products
so send again the request here to create
another product
which we
created so we can see it we have a
product in the other microservice
we need also to run this microservice
but we won't use the
command so i'll copy it here directly
i'll copy it
i'll run it here
i'll paste it here but here we need also
to change the port because the port 8000
is already occupied
so add
port here
8001
and this will run
this up on port
8001 and now let's send this request so
we'll send a request to http
localhost port 8001 this time
slash orders
we'll send a post request
and we will
send as we said an id
which in our case it is this id here
that we just created
and the quantity
and we will buy two products let's say
let's send this request
and indeed we got that product so
we are not
querying this product
in this microservice
instead we are sending an http request
to the other microservice
and we are retrieving the products from
here so
this is one way of microservices
communicating with each other
and now
we successfully got the product i will
cut this
the product will be equal to
request.json here
and we want to create this order so to
create that order
the order will be equal
to an order
and let's add all the values that we
need like the product
id
will be equal to body
id
we need the price
which is equal
to this product here because we don't
send it in the request so this is
product
price
the fee
this fee will be 20 of the products
price so this will be 0.2
times the product price
and the total will be the price plus the
fee
total here
so this means is 1.2 times the product
price
so that's it so this is a price the fee
is a total we need also the quantity
which we get it from the request body
and that's it we need also the status
which
the first case is pending
in the end we will save it so order
dot save
so
we successfully created an order here in
the end we will return the order
and
the only problem is this status pending
which
means that
we are waiting for a
payment processor to finish in order to
change this status
and for that
i'll create here another function
i'll call it
order completed
we'll pass the order here
as an order
and
what we want to do here is simply say
that the order
that
[Music]
status
is equal to completed
for the moment we will do it like this
order dot save
and we will call it here
order completed with an order so you may
ask yourself why i did it this way so we
will
make make this more complicated so don't
worry
first let's test if this is working
i will send
an order here
let's send this request
and indeed it works so we see we have a
primary key here so a new primary key
which means it's a primary key of the
order
this has this
product id this has this price fee total
quantity and in the end it is completed
so
this means that it went also to this
function change it to completed and it
is working fine
but let's say that
the payment processor needs five seconds
to confirm our order so i will add here
time
sleep
for 5 seconds
usually the payment processor
needs their time to confirm and so this
is a good estimation what happens if we
add this delay here
if we send another request right now
we will wait for five seconds till we
get the response
but this should not be the case because
we want to return the
pro the order with the status
pending and later on when it is
completed we want to change the status
how can we do that so
fast api supports asynchronous requests
like we did here
and
for that we need to create a background
task so
we need to import
i will import it here
from fast api
background import
background tasks
i will also cut time here and add it
here so
we have more space
and let's uh use now the background task
and
when we call the function here
i will add background
tasks
is a type of background tasks
i have also a typo here
and
we have this variable right now
and the way that we will use the
background tasks is like this so we will
use background tasks
other tasks and our task will be this
function here so i'll cut this
name and i'll put it here
if
this function does not have parameters
the background task
will be simply like this
but
this has an order as a parameter so all
the other parameters should be passed
after the name of the function
and that should be it
with this
fast api will execute this
function on the background
and let's see it
[Music]
before we test it i will add also
another endpoint here
i'll add it here on top
this will be a get request
because we need to see
if the order has changed so orders
with the primary key here
def
get
primary key as a string
and we will return order
get
with that primary theme
so we created this just to test it
and now
let's test it on the
postman now
let's send this request
the status is pending as we can see but
now let's open another tab
and let's
paste
this id
now the status it is completed so
i used five seconds to
request this so if i do it uh faster
this time so let's send this
this request i'll copy the primary key
paste it here
is still pending let's wait two more
seconds
and now it is completed so as you can
see this is indeed
executing in the background this is how
we execute functions in the background
in fast api
and now let's go to the other problem
which it is that every time we buy a
product
the the quantity should be subtracted
from the
inverter so the quantity here is 100
and we should decrease this value how do
we do that
we will do this by sending events
through redis streams so what are ready
streams
ready stream is
a messaging
event pass just like rabbit mq and kafka
so
you can read the documentation here
how it works so it has a lot of
functionalities
i will use just the basic ones
and
it will simply let us communicate via
different microservices
by sending events and they won't know
about each other
how do we do it
we will do it like this
the first step is sending the event to
the
uh ready streams and we already have a
redis connection here
and
when the order is completed
we change the status of the order and we
will send an event to redis
and the command is x add so this is a
command
in reddit streams we need a key
and the key will be order
completed
and we need a value
which in our case i will send directly
the order as it is so
this should be a dictionary as well
but fast api makes it uh easier for us
so i will send directly the order as a
dictionary like this
so
the order is sent
and the other parameter is a star
so this last parameter is the id of this
event
we can put it ourselves as we want but i
want
to have an auto generated id
so if you want uh now to generate id
just put a star here
and that should be it so this is the
event that we will send
and in our inventory here
we need to create a consumer so this
will wait for these events
for that i will create a new
python file i'll call it consumer here
and in this file first we need to add
the imports so from the main app
we need to import the redis connection
import redis and
we will import the product
and
what do we want to add here first i'll
create a variable key
which is equal to order
completed
and we need also a group
which i'll call this
inventory
group and let's create a redis consumer
group so i'll use a try accept here
and we will try to create
x group
create
with the key
and the group
so we will create a consumer group with
this key and this name
if it fails then we will print
group
already
exists
so we need
a consumer group in order to consume
and now
we need to consume and to do that we
need to add the
infinite loop here so while true
i'll use a try accept here as well
for the exception i want to print the
exception so exception as e here
and we will print
the exception as a string so like this
and inside the try
we will
consume and the way to consume is like
this
we'll get the results
redis
x read
group
and the parameters here first we need
the group
second we need the key
so it is the opposite as creating the
group so we need the key here and the
group but here we need the group and the
key
we need also two more parameters
uh the second one is
a dictionary that the
key will be our key
so it is order completed and we need to
add
this symbol which means that we want to
get all the events here
and
the second parameter the the last one is
none
and this is how we consume i will print
the results here
so to see what
is the type of
content that we are reading
and we need to add a timer so
while
we have an infinite loop here
i'll import
time here
and we will wait
sleep
for one second so every second we will
consume messages
and that should be it so now what is
left is to run this consumer
i will open a new tab and run python
consumer dot pi
and as you can see it is running
uh nostalgia
key order completed so it is running
and
this is waiting for the event in the
payment part which we will do it right
now
we will send an event when we create an
order let's send this
event
and we should be able to see
something here
in five seconds because we need to wait
that much
and uh
not sure if it is working i will
interrupt it and run it again
so we see an empty array actually
[Music]
so the message is different so this
means that
the key was created let's send another
event
then
we should probably wait uh five seconds
till we get
the response and indeed we got so i will
stop it here
and as you can see
we got an asynchronous event from redis
streams so
this is the order itself
this is a key order completed this is
the key of
the ready streams event
and this is the
order that we just created
and with this information
we will decrease the quantity
by 2 in the inventory microservice so
let's do that
and the way
that
i will do it right now
is uh first i'll make the condition if
results
is not an empty array
i will not print more empty arrays here
and then for each
result
in results so we can have multiple
events
because they are returned as a list
and the
object itself so this is what we want we
don't need the key we don't need the
event id here we just need this object
and that object
will be equal to result
we need the second
value of that list then the first one
then the second one so this is the way
how we get it
and
then we will get the product
which will be equal to product get
with the object
product underscore id
so
this is the id of the product that we
use in the order
and if the product is set
or i will print it directly so i will do
it like this so print
product
then i will decrease the quantity so
product that quantity
is equal to product that quantity again
minus
this
object
quantity
and i will convert this to an integer
because it will throw an error if we
don't do it
and we will save it so product
that save
and that should be it so
we get the event through ready streams
we loop the results we get the order
from that order we
get the product we decrease the quantity
and we save that product let's see if
this works i will save it
and
i will run it again and this time we get
the group already exist but we are not
getting empty arrays because i added the
if condition
here
and we are waiting to send this event
i send this event
so we need to wait five seconds
and
as we can see we got a
product print here so it got the product
that we want with the quantity of 100
and now if we query
again all the products
we can see that the quantity now is 98
so we decreased the quantity
asynchronously so
this is how it works we make a payment
for a product and we send events to
ready streams
to that microservice this microservice
doesn't know what happens in the other
microservice it just get events to
decrease the quantity of the products
so that's it our app it seems that is uh
almost completed
uh if you look at this app uh
with the functionalities it seems that
everything is handled
but there is
a small a rare problem that may happen
which is
in between this time period of five
seconds so in between this
time period we may have a problem that
if we don't handle it we will charge
customers for nothing basically
and that is the time when
for example i will copy this
endpoint
i will
create a new one
and this will be delete now
we want to delete this product with this
id
before i delete the id
uh
i will create an order for that product
and
if everything is successful
within five seconds i will delete that
product so let's do it now let's send
the request for the orders it is pending
let's delete the product
if we wait
i will copy the id of this order
this means that the order
was successful because now the status is
completed
the
customer was charged the order was
completed but the product was removed
uh one or two seconds
after the order was completed
this means that the customer was charged
and the product does not exist
how do we handle this case
so
these are rare problems but if you are
building event driven systems
you need to handle these problems
in this case
in our app what we will do is we will
refund
our customers so we will change the
status of the order to
refund it and we will send to the email
to the customers that
an error happens and
your payment has been refunded and to do
that
we need to send an event here
to the other microservice so we will
send
an event here
to the inventory and now we will send it
from the inventory back
and we will do it the same
so i'll copy this code
and i will make an if condition here for
the product
so
i'll do it like this if the product
is set
then we will decrease the quantity of
that product else
if the product does not exist so else
here
we will call redis we need to add the
so we need to send another event
which i'll call it refund
order
and the order in our case is this object
here which is already a dictionary so
i'll do it like this
so this is
the event in this part
this microservice has totally finished
now let's add the consumer which i will
copy again the consumer here and i'll
paste it here
to this microservice
of course we need to make changes here
we need to get the order
this is not order completed this is
refund
order
the group is a
payment group
so we need to create the group here
and we need to
make an infinite loop
here we get the
order
actually the order will be here
or the object i'll do it like this
object
then this is the order itself we will
get
the order from that primary key
order here
and we will change the status of the
order
status to
refunded
and we will save the order
and that should be it
so
this microservice now needs uh
to
call the consumer so python
consumer.pi
it is running
let's do the same for
this other microservice let's run the
consumer here as well
and let's uh
simulate that problem now so first we
will create a product which was created
we can see this is a product i'll copy
the id i'll paste it here just to be
ready to be deleted when we create an
order
and let's create an order now i'll
change the id send this and delete
immediately the product so
i think the problem now is that
the first time
the key won't be created that's why i'm
getting this message
let me stop it now and run it again
so
i will try to
do it like this then
so in the payment
uh when we get the order
i'll copy this
and i'll paste it here
i'll just say send an empty list here
just to create the key
and if i get this order so let's send a
get request
so we have a problem it seems
must be an empty dictionary so
then i will get the order
and i'll pass the order
to dictionary here
and i'll return the order
i'll run it again
and i will stop this
now it is working and if i run the
consumer
i won't have this problem that the
consumer is
was not created so as we see it is empty
here
and now we can simulate
that
the product deletion again so let's
create a product
it is appearing here
i'll copy the id
be ready to be deleted
and let's create another order
which
we have a mistake
so what is the mistake right now
so the mistake is because i forgot to
change the id here
and now let's send the request it is
spending delete the product
and now let's see the consumer
do we print something here
i don't think so so we don't print
anything but
for the order that we just created
let's see it here
and this time
i won't send
a random event here so i'll remove this
part i'll just return the order as it
was before
i'll save it
and we are still getting completed so i
figured out what is the reason the
reason is this if condition here is not
working
because
when it doesn't find the product
currently it throws an error so i have
to do a try accept here also
and we have multiple try catch
statements here
but let's hope if this
works then i will immediately create a
product now
i will
save this delete request
to do it immediately now when we create
an order
and let's delete it immediately and
let's see if we get a
deletion here
so actually
here we don't have
any print statements because i removed
it
so i added a print statement here on top
and as you can see
i retried again with a new order
and we actually get an event and uh for
this order that i created i will copy
this paste it here let's see if the
status now it is refunded so that's it
how it works
this is a
rare case but
anyway we need to handle also the rare
cases
in an event-driven architecture so
that's it this were the microservices
that i wanted to
build
now let's build the front end
so now it's time to create the front end
and
i'm in a in the folder now with where i
have the inventory and the payment
microservice
and now i will use the command mpx
create react
up
i'll call it front end
or i'll call it inventory
front-end
and let's wait till it's completed right
now
so it is completed i open it with my ide
so this is the front end now and i have
the back ends running
in other tabs but we won't change those
let's work with the front end i will
remove the test file
and this up css
we need to adjust our app.js
and our index.css so for the app.js i
will change the html here
i'll go to
boots gets bootstrap.com
click get started and let's copy the
bootstrap css
i'll paste it here on the index.html
and for the html here go to examples and
go to
dashboard
here
let's view the page source and i'll copy
the code from the
container fluid or from the header i
guess
until the end
and i will replace this html here
with
the one that i just copied
but we need to make a lot of changes
here for example
this table we need just a table row we
don't need all the other
table rows so
from the end
until here
i will remove everything so we need
just one table row
we don't need the section title neither
the canvas
i will remove also this
div here
we don't need it
for the menu
we have two kinds of menu so this
ul here i will remove it along with this
h6 here
and we need this ul but we need only one
list item so i will keep
the dashboard
and and for the header
we don't need
this button
this
input
we don't need it
and what is left here so something
is wrong i guess
or not so let me format it i'll save it
run npm
start
and let's see how it looks like so if we
open it on the browser
it will look like this still we need
some css
because this dashboard has this
dashboard css here so in the in the
paste source click dashboard css
select all the
css there and add it to the index css
here
i'll save it
if we see now our react app it will look
better now
let's make
other changes
for example the dashboard here i'll
rename it to products
i'll remove this spawn
and it will look like this
and here we need to render our products
but
i will create components i want to do it
directly
so first i will create
a new directory components
and inside i will create a products
component so this will be a javascript
file
products
and
i will export a constant here products
this will be equal to a function that we
will return here
an html and that html will be
this
table here
so i will cut the code
and i will return it here
so this is the products
component for the moment
and
for the other html that is left i will
create another component i'll call it
wrapper
because we will reuse this wrapper to
another component so that's why i split
that html into two different components
so
i'll export a constant
wrapper
that this will contain
all this
html
in the wrapper i will return
the
html so i will remove this class name up
and also the div in the beginning so
i'll keep it like this
and
here we want to display our products.js
we can do it like this so i'll add here
the props
and inside our main
div here i'll add props
that children
and this wrapper will be used in our
products.js because we will wrap this
html with the wrapper
i'll cut it i'll put it here
and that's it so this is our products is
rapid is wrapped with this wrapper
component
and here we can simply return our
products
like this
and if we save
if we go back nothing will change
but our code will look much better
now let's add the the
router so we need to install a package
npm install
react router dom
so this will
let us
map the routes so we will have more
components we don't we won't have just
the products here
and first we need to import
from
react
router dom
we need to import
browser router
routes
and route
so
now this will change this return
statement to this first i will use the
browser router
inside
this will have the routes
and for all the routes we need
the specific routes so
we have only one route for the moment
which is the path is
just the main path and the element
is our
products
components like this
so if we go to the main path we will
render our products component i will
save this
and nothing will change again
now
we are finished with app.js every time
we create a new component we need to add
a new route here so for the moment let's
make the products work so here we are
displaying just an html but this should
be
the list of the products and to do that
we have to create a variable here
products
set products
will be equal to use state
and the default state will be an empty
array
and
to get the products we have to use here
use effect
and we need to make a request to the
backend let's add first the dependencies
which should be an empty array
this means that we will use use effect
only once if we add
the empty array here
and inside
i will call an asynchronous function
like this
because usefx does not support
adding a synchronous function here on
top it will throw an error that's why we
need to create this
and i created an asynchronous function
because now we will send an asynchronous
request so we'll get a response
is equal to await
fetch
http
localhost so http
localhost
port 8000
slash
products
and
the content
it will be equal to a weight response
json
so this is the content
so
this content will be our products and we
will call here set products to the
content
and that should be it we added the
products here
and we should loop them here so
let's loop the products so products
map
product
we will return
this
html where the key we need to add the
key for when we make for loops in react
so the key will be the product dot id
and the values will be
actually let's add them first here
on top so
the first value is id which is correct
then we need the name
the price
the quantity
and the actions
and when we loop the product we will
display the product
dot id here
i'll copy paste it here this is name
this is a
price
this is the quantity
and for the actions
this will be just an anchor link
with an href to
hashtag
we need to add these class names which
are button
button
small
button
outline
secondary
and we need to close it and we will call
delete here
and that should be it
so let's see it uh here
we can see that
we are showing here a table
if we inspect
we're calling the products but
momentarily we don't have any products
so we need to create
the component to create those products
and i'll create it now so this will be
the products
create component
before we add any code i will go to the
products and i will add a button here on
top
and that will be
this
html with the link so
this will look like
this so we have another button here
that will navigate to the create page
which will be this products create
and
we are using a link here which we import
from react router dom so we can navigate
to that page
also that page should be added on our
routes here but first we need to
export
the constant product create
and we need to return some html so i'll
return the div here
so we can add it here
so the path now will be create
and the element is product
create
so we added the second route
now let's add the html here so we don't
need this div we need to add here a form
i will add the class for the form so
class name here
margin top should be three
and for all the inputs i will use this
format here so we need this class name
and we need
an input here so the first input will be
the name so for the placeholder i will
put here name
and inside the label i'll put name again
and i'll do the same for the other
inputs which are the
price
and the last one
is
the quantity
we need also a button
so i preset
the button also with this classes
and with submit inside
and this form
will look so let's let me click there we
will go there and
we can see only the form here
which is not correct because i forgot to
wrap it with the wrapper i'll add here
the wrapper
and i will close it
and if i save it we can see the form now
we have a name a price and a quantity
for the price and quantity i will make
the type here to a number
same for the quantity
and this inputs now will have this
arrows up and down
now let's make this form work so for
each input now i'll create a variable so
we need
a name
set name is equal to use state
empty
and same for the other inputs which are
the price
set price
and this is the quantity
set quantity
and now
for all the inputs when we make a change
so on change here we will have an event
that will set the name to
event.target.value
we will do the same for
all the other inputs
so this is set
price
and this is
set quantity
and we got all the values now it's time
to submit the form so i will create a
function here
submit
and when we submit here
on submit
we will call that submit function
this will have an event
and what do we want to do here is we
need to prevent default
because if we don't add this line
when we submit here it will refresh the
page and
that is not what we want
so that's it now what is left is to send
the request to the backend so we will
make this asynchronous
and we will await here
fetch
will send an http request
localhost port 8000 slash
products
and this time the the method will be a
post request
we need to add the headers
which are
content
type
will be application
json
and we need to send the information that
we need which are these three variables
here and we'll send that in the body
which
should be a string so we need to use the
function json stringify
and the object that we need to send is
the name will have the value of name but
since they have the same key and the
value
i can use it directly like this so i
added the name
the price and the quantity and that's it
this is the request that we want in
order to create the product
and when we are finished so if this is
successful i want to navigate back to
the products and we will use
the function navigate
is equal to use navigate
so
y is not imported so
we need to import
use navigate
from
react
router dom
and
when this request
completes successfully we will await
navigate
i'll pass here minus one which means
that go to the previous page
and with this
let's try to create our first product
product
the price will be 20 and the quantity
will be 100 submit
we redirected back we created the
product we have an id here the name the
price and the quantity so
everything works fine
we need also to add the functionality to
delete a product so let's add it now so
we have this
incorrectly which does nothing for the
moment
let's create a delete function
i'll call it deal because delete is a
keyword
and this function will accept
this will be asynchronous will accept
an id
and if we scroll down
i will add here on click
and when we
get an event
we will call delete
with the product id inside
so
we have the product id let's go back
and
the first thing that we need to do once
we delete something is to
make a confirmation window so window
confirm
are
you sure
to delete
this record
so every time you delete something make
sure to
ask them the confirmation window
and if they type ok we will await fetch
[Music]
http
localhost port 8000
slash
products slash the id that we just
passed here
and if that is successful so
we need also to add the method here
which is delete
if that is successful then from the
products here we have to
remove that product
and we will do it like this so set
products
to products but we have to filter
we have to filter all the products
that the product that id
is different than this id that we just
removed
and that's it
so
let's test it now
are you sure you want to delete this
record okay and it is removed if i
refresh we won't see that record so we
need to create another product
with a new price
a new quantity
and it will it works successfully now
is time to add the other front end for
the other microservice so
again this should be another app so we
need to create another react app
in order to add the micro the front end
for the payment microservice but i will
still do it in this
front end
because it won't make a difference i
already explained the concepts that i
wanted to teach you so
adding a new react app won't add
anything new to this project so
that's it with this i will create
a new
component here and i will call it orders
and
let's export
this constant orders
and for the html
i will paste it it directly
so this is the html that i want to show
there
so to see what it looks like
we need to add it also to the routes so
the path here will be orders
and the element will be
orders so don't forget to import that
also
and if we open the browser i'll open a
new tab here i'll close this other tabs
and this is slash orders
and this is the checkout form so
think of it as a new microservice
it is the same app but it won't make a
difference if we create a new react app
so
here we create the products and here we
buy them and the way that we want to buy
them is we will copy here the
id of the product and we will pass the
quantity here so
let's go to the orders now
first let's make
for each input let's make a variable
here so
i'll add the id
set id
this will be equal to use state
empty by default
and we need also the quantity
and this is set quantity
and when we change those values
we change them here
so on change
we will set
the id here event.target.value
and we will do the same for the quantity
set quantity
so
we got those values and now we need to
submit the form so
let's create a function here
submit
let's add it here on submit
we will call a submit function
this will be an asynchronous
function this will get the event and we
need to prevent default
and
here we want to send a request to the
backend so wait
fetch
localhost
port 8000
not 8 000 sorry 8001 in this case
because we are
sending a request to the payment
microservice so this is 8001 slash
orders
this should be a post request
and we need to
add the headers
i'll copy them from here
so the headers and the body
and if i go here i'll paste it here
so the headers are the same and the body
is sending this information but we don't
need the name and the price we need to
send just an id
and the quantity
and if everything is set
then
i will display a message here
so i'll cut this
i'll create a variable message
message
set message
is equal to use state default message is
by your favorite products
and when it's completed we'll set the
message to
thank you
for
your
order
and i will show the message here
and that should be it so
this will look like this let's uh try to
purchase this product
the quantity is three let's buy the
product and as we can see thank you for
your order and if we refresh this
we will see 117
so we should wait five seconds till this
value changes
and everything is working as it should i
will adjust a small change so our app is
perfectly working i will
add the use effect here
that this use effect will depend on the
id
so every time we change the id here
the input
we want to
we want to display another message here
so the product price is this much
so
i'll first make an asynchronous function
here
and
i will use a try catch
because we may have a problem
in in case that we have an error i'll
set the message to
uh
the same message that was all the time
so be buy your favorite product
and
if the id is set
then we will send
a message so
request sorry
wait
fetch to http localhost port
8000 slash
products
so i'll change the quotes here because
we need to use these
because i will pass the id of the
product here
we'll get the content
which is equal to a weight
response
json
and we will set the message to
your
product
price
is
in dollars and i'll put here the value
content dot price
and let's see if this is working fine
so i will use double dollar signs
because we need an actual dollar sign
here
so if i refresh
i will copy this value paste it here and
as you can see your product price is 25
dollars
so
i will make a small change also now so
the price will be equal to
we need to parse it to float so parts
float
times 1.2 since we are the
uh 20
in this microservice so the actual price
will be more than that
and
as you can see now your product price is
30. so this is a inventory
we are selling the price
we are selling the product with the
price of 25
and in another app that is using those
products
we add the fee of 5 dollars so this is
how microservices work
and thank you for watching this video
don't forget to like share and subscribe
thank you